any kind of funny stories from the
process of writing the book and anything
that didn't make it into the book that
uh that you just found either funny or
you think people would enjoy hearing
about yeah definitely a couple of fun
suck stories if you're up for them first
is so I knew Zuckerberg used a snapchat
and I kind of wanted to get him into
this position where he admitted it to me
and so I'm telling him you know we're
talking about stories and I have an idea
of how stories came to be you know again
as part of the feedback culture people
telling him that you need to do this or
else your products are gonna die and I I
knew that he was using snapchat and he
alluded to like you know watching
stories and I was like so you did it on
snapchat and he goes well and Instagram
I was like but you use snapchat and he
goes yeah but I use all of our
competitors products and then he said um
he said he was when Facebook was
starting to experiment into the dating
app scene he had to try them out so he
got onto the dating apps with his own
picture he started experimenting with
them and he said he was on this one app
where you match with a new person every
day and he thought it was a cool looking
app so he showed it to his wife
Priscilla he goes hey Priscilla check it
out you know here's this dating app
that's pretty interesting and she looked
at the person on screen and was
scheduled to have dinner with her next
night so anyway it it's kind of one of
those stories where I'm like okay I'm
sitting here next to Zuckerberg and he's
telling me he's using dating out to meet
his widest friends that's interesting
yeah I mean and look I think part of
that is like it's funny right and and
you know one those are great stories but
two is it also shows the level of maybe
obsessions the wrong word but but just
really wanting to understand how
technology works what are other people
doing what should we be doing right and
being critical of products and I've said
over and over again you know mark
was probably one of the only people I've
ever met that could sit in a room and
talk about high-level strategy of an
entire division within a you know
multinational corporation and then
literally during the demo zoom in and
pick up you know why is that pixel off
right and just the ability to kind of go
up and down and one time somebody said
to me who'd been to coming a long time
they said look you got to remember that
mark has more context than anybody else
who works here
he's working on it longer than everybody
so he has the story behind every single
of these products he's seen them all get
developed and all this and and if you
kind of go across all the major tech
companies that is one thing that remains
constant is most of them are still run
by their founders or the founders are
still in some sort of influential
position which I'm assuming that you
kind of saw as one of those patterns
across the companies right totally and I
think that like you're right the way
that he's using these apps shows a
willingness to believe in a product
outside of Facebook right but the
problem that companies get into is they
believe that their software is the best
therefore they'll never even try another
person's software and like to me was
surprising that Zuckerberg is using
snapchat and dating apps but like
looking back of course he is like Amazon
has an interesting leadership principle
called invent and simplify and the idea
is you know you invent and then you
build systems to make sure you're not
spending too much time supporting that
existing product but they say explicitly
you know we don't have this dedication
to building to using stuff only invented
here if something was invented elsewhere
we'll use it and we're going with
best-of-breed you contrast that with
Microsoft when Steve Ballmer was running
Microsoft you couldn't bring the Apple
product into the campus you know Steve
Ballmer once pretended to throw an
iPhone in a meeting with people so
people sort of knew if I'm working on a
Mac even from developing for Mac users
I'm gonna get a dirty look if I'm
working on on this computer and Apple
came and sorry Microsoft canvas and I
think it sort of shows when you have a
willingness and an appreciation to ideas
from anywhere when you have a
willingness to admit that other
companies are developing good software
and you want to learn why they've done
well then you're going to be
sheep but when you want to sort of you
know again look and protect your asset
and think that that's the only thing
that matters in the world and that all
your competitors don't have a chance in
the world that arrogance ends up leading
to bad business outcomes